Uh, okay, let's go to cool depth.
Oh two.
That's how I have this person who's from China.
Cool.
Dep too.
I don't know what that means.
Is that, is that your name?
Yeah.
Hey, no.
Hey, how you doing is cool.
Dry.
Cool.
Yes, sir.
Uh, I think that's still my name on a, yeah.
Yeah.
Cool.
Drop below two on a, on.
Okay.
Hi.
Yeah, it's me.
Yeah.
I'm, I'm way more sober and for everyone.
I'm actually watching.
No, I wasn't doing the wacky tobacky.
I'm not trying to get my mother, I'm not trying
to get my head chopped off.
Also, I want to shout out live in China, right?
Yes, sir.
Yes, I do.
I live and work in China.
Uh, I'm also, uh, thank you.
I appreciate that.
I want to shout out seven, five, seven.
James, I'm actually originally from seven,
five, seven at Newport News, Virginia.
Well, yeah, at least that I'm Newport News
City, Virginia and uh, the surrounding areas.
They could also be your county.
That was pretty cool to hear.
One from my area, that's pretty dope.
But I do have a, an assessment, a question
or topic, the three war in a sense that has
happened on the farmers that I'm abroad and
in our country.
And I feel like I'm, the India is really undercutting
the sex, the devastating effects of having,
um, domestically and abroad.
Uh, for wonderful, for instance, a few of
my friends that really into the market, we,
uh, we use this, uh, this, uh, app in China,
coal we chat and if they're really talking
about how, um, to suffer it from a full sort
of shortage of sorts.
And right now they're actually a calling a
bunch of hogs here, um, in, in, in time.
Um, and a lot of them think, uh, think that
because it is trade war is going to effect
their imports of, of what they, they, the,
that desire to most support.
And um, I actually told them, Yo, did you
know that in our, in my state in Virginia,
in Va, they own Smithfield packing meat, packing
a Tanya's company owned Smithfield meatpacking,
which is one of the largest meatpacking companies
in the world.
Right?
Especially when it comes to pork products
and there no terrorist on port.
Okay.
I will
an objective, but the question itself is,
uh, how do you feel, how do you help him?
What do you know about, um, or how do you
think, uh, the tariffs are really actually
going to set China when it comes to food?
Uh, um, grant and magnetic, considering the
fact that they own a large percentage of our
farming, our farm lane and our, and our meat
packing company.
If I couldn't address that industry specifically,
but from the, from the sort of long form,
more academic analyses of the terrorists that
I've read, China is much better positioned
to weather the effect of the tariffs.
Then is the United States, both in terms of
the countries that China, uh, the options
that China has in terms of shifts to their
economy relative to the options that they
made.
It states as the overall opinion.
I can't speak about the meat industry specifically,
is that China is going to be able to much
ease much more easily whether the effects
of the tariffs then the United States.
That's what I, that was my thoughts because
I'm one, they have, they have so many options
and one of the options that they have is the
United States in itself.
And if not being wholeheartedly addressed,
like Yo, wait, um, China owns Inbev.
China owns Smithfield.
Uh, I say China owns because you know, if
a company in China owns something, China owns
it.
Sure.
In, in, um, either the things that a lot of
my friends especially like, um, the, the more
educated ones day, then I feel like didn't,
they're really overlooking.
Okay.
Yeah.
My question is how to drop.
I think you're making a very good point.
And it's interesting actually being there
firsthand and seeing it.
And by what Rema do you teach English in China?
Remind us what you do.
Okay.
Oh No, I think ceramics and teach social studies.
You said this is a, these are, these are topics
that I, I, you know, dive into.
I'm sorta like you what?
I watch a lot more videos than you do.
Okay.
And Are you like, are you living there permanently
or are you there for a specific amount of
time?
I, I'm, I go back and forth.
I normally visit during the summer and I come
back during the school year and traveled during
their holidays.
They're nice.
And you like you like living there?
I do.
I actually do.
Um, I'm safe.
I haven't been, I'm pulled over by any gaps.
I can actually walk near cop whistling a backwards
saying skip anything.
They won't, oh, excuse me.
Sorry.
Oh, I did it again.
Don't worry.
They won't say anything.
Appreciate it.
That you'd man.
Yep.
Um, and uh, I, I, I will say this, my sense
of safety is higher.
I'm not sure if you can tell which most like
you can.
I'm Afro American.
Okay.
And uh, and uh, overall I like it here, uh,
in Yo for what foreigners they normally don't
do too much, but right now they're actually
cracking down.
Sorry.
Are you saying you feel safer as a black man
in China than in the United States?
Yes, I do.
And I, and I will actually tell, I will actually
get some of my more of my friends, my colleagues
and people I share, we chat groups with the
call into your show and they will share a
similar sentiment
please.
All right.
I look forward to hearing from them.
I will correct your name and not cool depth.
Otu We will update it to cooled drop route
two from China.
I gotcha.
Okay.
Thank you so much for the call.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Okay, take care.
Bye.